William D. Eggers is coauthor with
Donald F. Kettl of the new book
"Bridge Builders: How Government
Can Transcend Boundaries to Solve
Big Problems".
Now, executive director of Deloitte
Center for Government Insights.
30 years ago, Eggers ran
the Privatization Center for Reason
Foundation, the nonprofit that
publishes Reason magazine.
He's worked with dozens of
governments at all levels, both
in the United States and
internationally.
And he's written a shelf's worth of
books on the proper scope and
functioning of government.
I talked with him about Bridge
Builders and what he's learned over
the past three decades about making
government more effective and less
intrusive when confronting major
challenges such as pandemics
and why it's long past time to
move beyond what he and his coauthor
call "the vending machine
model of government".
Well. Eggers, thanks for
talking to Reason.
It's great to see you again,
Nick.
We've known each other 30 years
now.
Yes, that is.
It's kind of sobering, right?
Your new book is "Bridge
Builders: How Government Can
Transcend Boundaries to Solve Big
Problems". You coauthored it
with Donald F Kettl.
What's the elevator pitch of "Bridge
Builders"?
Basically, our political
and policy debates are mostly
based on an outdated mental
model of what we term
"the vending machine mental model
of government", which is you have a
big problem.
You pass a law.
You fund an organization.
You put money into the vending
machine and you're expected to
produce results.
That's what we read about in the
newspapers.
We see it on TV, and that doesn't
reflect either how government
operates or how you can actually
solve any big problems today,
like take a problem like
homelessness.
Is it an economic
problem? Is it a mental health
problem? Is it a housing problem,
a crime problem,
or and whose responsibility is
it? Is it local government, state
government, federal government,
non-profits, foundations,
the private sector care?
And the answer for all those
questions is yes.
And so what we need is a new
model to look at public management
and government that reflects the
reality of a big blurring
of the lines, really, between the
public and private sector.
And the key to effective government
today is really the ability
to effectively
manage these public private
networks.
Before we get into some specifics
about stuff, let's reflect a little
bit on your history, both at Reason
Foundation.
When I interviewed
for a job and I joined in
October of 93, you were already
working there. You know, you're like
Bartleby, the Scrivener.
You were there in the office when
the guy shows up in the office,
but you were running, or
you eventually ran a center
for privatization.
And talk a
bit about, you know,
when in the early nineties, when
your career started, what
were the challenges and what
has become because you're talking
about the vending machine model is
outmoded. That's not how governments
operate. What were they?
You know, how did that happen?
You know, I started off right out of
college working at
Reason of what was then called the
local government center.
And it was really doing the nitty
gritty of kind of
the local government management.
And how do you deliver garbage
collection or wastewater treatment
in areas and, of course...
The school buses, things like that.
And at the time, people wanted to go
to think tanks and do sexy policy
things. And I originally thought, oh
my gosh, what is this?
And then I saw just how
important that work is.
And it's also a lot of work that
most think tanks don't do.
They don't do implementation.
They just want to debate policy
ideas. So that's what made
Reason, and then the local
government center and then the
privatization center and center for
government reform so unique.
And at that time, there was a lot
of debate really about
who should be providing
these different services.
Should it be the public sector,
the private sector, sort of the
mixed thing. And there's a large
debate. That debate is is largely
over today.
My friend Steve
Sarvis
wrote literally 35
years ago about how government
should steer, not grow.
And increasingly
that is no longer something
that is debated, whether
it doesn't matter on the Republican
side, the Democrat side, what
ideology you have.
Increasingly government is playing
the role of steering
rather than actually.
And funding as well, Right?
I mean, like a lot of the money.
And one of the things that was
fascinating in the book, I didn't
realize you talk about
how in during the Manhattan Project,
like a ton of that stuff was
outsourced to private industry
because one of your previous books,
you know, if we can put a man on the
Moon, dot, dot, dot,
it's kind of there's a long
tradition going back
really centuries.
In Ben Franklin's autobiography
talks about, you know, fulfilling a
contract that he got,
a governmental contract that he got
for delivering stuff to the
border or the frontier in the French
and Indian War and stuff.
But the Manhattan Project.
Talk a little bit about how like
they farmed out different parts of
that.
And wasn't it was the Manhattan
Project where then General
Leslie Groves
was the person who was in charge of
this, and he had to find
a way to build the atomic
bomb, but do it in a lab
with a lot of secrecy.
And there was a little
he tens of thousands of
academic researchers and people.
Both from private industry
and some government who are all
working on different elements of it.
And growth was one of just a few
people who knew how all the
different parts were working,
and that actually we saw the very
similar model in the Apollo mission
when we first first put a man on the
move. That was James Webb,
who listened to Kennedy's
call and and
he was instrumental in organizing
this vast network.
And when you look at the Apollo
mission, it was over 22,000
different firms that were involved
in that academic research
centers everywhere, NASA's
employees.
And so we have this history
of doing big things.
And when we do it, it's usually
through these very blended models.
And and I think in many
respects, the U.S.
has really led the way, you know,
probably over centuries and
and developed these sort of very
sophisticated network models.
But it's hard to find something
that we've done that you can say a
really big accomplishment that
wasn't done in this sort of a model.
When you were starting
out at reason and whatnot.
One of the big books that was in the
air and concepts was Reinventing
Government, which
Al Gore and
I'm struggling to remember
his name, Bill Clinton.
You know, it's funny how quickly
people kind of fade from
consciousness, but they you
know, they were talking a lot.
That was part of their pitch as like
New Democrats that they were going
to reinvent government.
Can you talk a little bit about that
book and how that is?
You know, that has had like a
serious influence along with, you
know, people like Bob Poole and
Steve Savage, you know, talking
about privatization.
Well, absolutely.
Actually, David Osborne, one of the
coauthors of Reinventing government,
actually gave us a nice blurb
for this book.
But that book really did
usher in a whole wave
of government reform and a focus
on good government, effective
government in a nonpartisan way
during the nineties. And that for
those of us who've been looking at
public management and that's for me,
it's three and a half decades, that
was really the heyday of a
lot of that. We saw a lot
of very business minded mayors
who focused on pragmatic things
that make new cities run, like Steve
Goldsmith from Indianapolis, who I
wrote a book with.
You had Ed Rendell from
Philadelphia.
There was a Democrat, Al
Smith, a Republican.
And a Democrat.
And then a lot of governors like
William Weld, who's been featured.
And you've had on your show before,
and John Engler and others.
So it was a really big focus.
And one of the reasons why got
so much attention, of course, was
because Bill Clinton
was seen during his campaign
actually walking around with it.
And then, of course, famously,
Al Gore went on the David
Letterman show and he
looked at these ashtrays that cost
so much. And then they had big
forklifts that they showed all these
government regulations.
So they did a really nice job
messaging in kind of making
government reform sexy.
Yeah. What was the what was
the impetus? Was it a
sense because this is, you know,
coming after the Reagan years
and, you know, Reagan was
a revolutionary or whatever, but
he was very popular.
H.W. Bush,
you know, was kind of popular until
he lost reelection.
But like, why were Democrats
championing a new way
of delivering government services?
Was it? And I guess was it because
they had failed in the older
model, or were we out of money?
Like what were the pressures saying
we got to do something different?
Well, I think, you know, some of it
was, of course, a lot of the New
Democrat mantra.
And there was thinktanks like the
Progressive Policy Institute,
led by Will Marshall and my friend
Rob Atkinson, who were putting out
studies along these lines.
And really people were looking
at a lot of the sclerosis
that was occurring at the time and a
lot of our big cities and government
institutions.
And really how do you how do you
fix that?
And so it was
not only, though, the Democrats, you
had a lot of these real reform
minded Republicans who
made this a big part of their
governing philosophy at the
state level, from Tom Ridge
to William William Weld,
Tommy Thompson out of Wisconsin
and others.
Is it easier?
I guess it is easier to do
it at the state or local
level or that that's where the
delivery of services really kind
of takes place?
It is where the delivery of services
takes place, although under the
Reinventing Government initiative, I
mean, they did reduce the size
of the government workforce more
than we've ever seen any
administration do it.
And they been basically down to
the same size that as when John
F Kennedy was president.
Which is kind of fascinating because
the government is I mean, Bill
Clinton's last budget,
I think, was $2 trillion
in nominal dollars.
You know, we're now spending over 6
trillion. On a regular basis, it
seems. But the amount of workers
paid by the federal government is
smaller.
Right. And that really shows a big
point of our book is that
most of what government does
today through the federal government
is not direct government paying
employees and so on.
It's through what are called
indirect tools of government.
It's through tax credits and
contracts and grants
and loan guarantees
and areas like that.
And we actually estimate in
the book that about 94%
of the federal budget is
through these sort of more indirect
tools of government as
opposed to direct government action.
Yeah, I'm looking at I mean, this
was one of the things that really
made my head explode
in table five, Dash
one. You talk about the federal
government's financial footprint and
out of total outlays and you
you come to a number you know,
there's the this is from 2021
so it was $6.8 trillion,
which is a record which I suspect
will be broken sometime within the
next five years.
But, you know, a chunk
of that is a large
chunk of that is through things like
tax expenditures, which
are tax cuts or tax loopholes,
subsidies and things like that,
loans and whatnot.
And so the total footprint
of the financial footprint of the
federal government is more like
11.7 trillion.
And you say only about 458
billion of that is,
you know, the government putting
a check in some of these pocket.
Exactly. So we we end up,
you know, having all of these
debates about a tiny little
percentage of the actual
government budget right now.
And in fact, when you look at
how especially in the United States,
when we're trying to realize
different policy goals or have
behavioral changes or do
various things, increasingly
policymakers are using
these indirect tools because
they don't have to say they're
growing the size of government
before, and they're trying to
oftentimes catalyze
markets and catalyze the private
sector to do various things to
achieve broader goals that they
might have, whether it's climate
action or workforce development.
Let's go through a couple of
specific examples of
where government beat them over
the past couple of decades has
successfully, you know,
solved big problems or address them.
What is the what's your top of mind
example for that?
Well, you know, I mentioned,
of course, the Apollo mission and
written a lot about NASA's
over the years, because I do
think it's an exemplar agency.
And even when you look at the
commercial space industry, which
I'm incredibly bullish on
space and what's going to happen
there, the commercial space
industry would not exist anywhere
near it exists today without NASA.
NASA's playing a role as
a catalyzing of this industry.
And in fact, in Walter Isaacson's
new book about Elon Musk, I don't
know if you've read. I have.
No idea.
It's a it's a great read.
Yeah. Known Walter a long time And
he's got a quote from Elon Musk
where Space X almost went
bankrupt at one point.
They're in real trouble and
then they got an anchor
contract from Naza
that allowed them to then start
investing. And even Musk,
who is a huge fan of government,
as you know, he at one point he had
as his password to his computer.
I love NACA.
Yeah. So NASA's done a really good
job of being what we call a catalyst
by design.
Okay, let's let's dig into that a
little bit. Musk We did a video
about him a couple of years ago
about, you know, he is more
than a master of markets.
He's a master of getting government
subsidies and incentives for
sure.
To walk through that, because NASA's
you know, after the Apollo,
you know, mission kind of and
whatnot, they generally the knock on
NASA's that it's a really
bureaucratic
kind of stuck in its way risk
averse culture.
So but but
you're right and you document this
in the book that NASA is the
reason why there is a big private
space, you know, kind of industry
that's going how how does this work
and how does it show the new
kind of blended government model
rather than that the vending machine
model?
Well, if you think about NASA's and
without the commercial space
industry, without the sort of all
the incentives that they created
for that to flourish, NASA's
might need to be two or three times
as large to do what
you know, what they're doing right
now in terms of space travel right
now. So what they did was they
had a big change a couple of decades
ago, starting with Charlie Bolden,
who we talk about in
the book, where they said we're
going to focus on catalyzing
innovation.
We're going to focus on creating
incentives and systems to
to actually get the.
Private sector essentially to
to build what we need to meets
the mission of Nasser.
But also at the same time to expand
the opportunities for space travel.
And so they've done hundreds
of prizes and challenges, open
competitions for from an
innovation standpoint.
They use tools like competitive
grants and, of course, their
procurement contracts.
They have over 20 different
technologies, people who
are just focusing on what are the
technologies in these different
markets and how how are
they progressing?
How important are they for for
NASA's. So they're doing market
sensing at the same time, and
they're creating a lot of channels
to academia and private industry.
And I think increasingly that's
really the future of government
agencies.
Hmm.
And was that mostly under Obama
that these shifts took place
a lot?
The ships have been going on for a
while, but yes, big acceleration
under under President Obama.
And what's interesting, if you look
at a big acceleration, this
notion of public private
partnerships, the Obama
administration was a big driver
of these and everything from space
and we saw it. And the defense world
beside and even areas like foreign
aid and
and elsewhere. But it's not just you
know that administration in that in
the George W Bush administration,
our former colleague Lynn Scarlett,
was the assistant secretary of
interior.
And one of her major accomplishments
was to really drive public
private partnerships in the national
parks, to really improve
that and bring the community is more
into the administration
of parks.
Are there you know,
are are there any surprising
challengers to this kind of thing?
And I know, like when you talk about
something like the national parks
and then you say, you know what,
we're going to contract out,
you know, the vending machines
or the, you know, the franchises and
a bunch of the amenities and maybe
even the upkeep and stuff, You
know, like obviously anybody who is
a public sector employee is going to
be like, now this is, you know, a
sacred trust.
And you can't have, like, you know,
private contractors.
They pay less and they you know,
they don't care, etc..
But who you know, who else are the
surprising people who are like, no,
now we really have to keep
the government, you know, directly
funding everything?
Well, I think what we really try to
focus on in the book, in my my
coauthor, Don Kettl, is kind
of the dean of public management in
the US, has written 25 books
on public management.
So it's very much a non-ideological,
nonpartisan look at
this.
And increasingly, the debates are
not about whether something
is contracted out or not.
It's about what's the right mix
between the public and private
sector. And what we try to focus on
in the book is that the private
sector is now putting in
essentially trillions of dollars
into creating different
elements of private public
value.
And so how can government leverage
that? So it's a lot less about
necessarily who should be delivering
that service, but how do you bring
the different sectors together to
produce the most public value?
That's that's how Houston
has been able to reduce homelessness
by 63%.
At the same time, when it was going
up and.
Explain how they did that what what
does the you know, the kind of local
government of Houston do and
or you know, to the extent that it
matters the state government in the
federal government like how how does
Houston figure out how to fix
homelessness. I live in New York
City.
They're not doing such a great job
of it. And certainly there's a lot
of West Coast cities that are just
really abysmal.
Yeah, I mean, Houston is now put
over 26,000 individuals
and permanent housing over the last
decade, three fourths of whom
stay in permanent housing,
63% reduction,
which we haven't seen almost
anywhere else to that extent.
And there's a couple of key elements
to it. Certainly.
Number one is they've taken the
funding from federal, state, local
level foundations
and individuals and companies,
and they've been able to bucket a
lot of the funding together, which.
Explains.
Well, because the siloed funding
processes are one of the biggest
obstacles to doing a lot.
When you look at most of our
problems, they go beyond
the boundaries, the legislative
boundaries that have been set for
them.
And so what they need to do is
Houston, they took funding from HUD
or HHS or the state
level and they were able to then
put pool all of that money.
And then there's a nonprofit
called the Houston Coalition for the
Homeless, over 100 different
provider organizations.
And Mike Nichols was the orchestra
conductor kind of, because that's
how we look at this, A, bringing
all those organizations together.
And another key element is just
the data system that they created.
So previously, before
they got started down this road, the
mayor and Elise Parker then would
say that you could be having
different organizations and.
Again, these are mostly nonprofit
organizations, some for delivering
services to a homeless individual
and not knowing what other services
they'd gotten, not knowing where
they were in the journey. They
couldn't talk to each other, they
couldn't share information,
and they built a system so that they
could share all that in in real
time, that they can measure outcomes
and they could see, well, this
individual, this is the services
that they need, the services they've
received, and they can be monitoring
that at all times.
So they went from being kind of just
a number to really the kind of
the life history of each individual
glued together by the state.
Side, primarily, you know, in the
name of the book is bridge Builders.
And you talk a lot you mentioned the
phrase an orchestra conductor,
you know, where somebody who is
overseeing everything, right?
So it's like Leslie Groves or
whatever.
Is this you know, is it primarily
individuals who,
you know, you have to have the right
individual in place or is it a
systems approach so that you are,
you know, and how do you balance
that?
It's it's definitely both.
We found, you know, we profiled
dozens of these amazing, amazing
bridge builders across all the
different sectors.
And it's really hard work.
You have to look out for bridge
builder burnout.
And one of the keys to being good at
this is understanding deeply how
each of the sectors work.
And sometimes those are called tri
sector athletes, people who have
worked across the sectors.
So what is it that the government,
private industry and nonprofit?
Yes. Yeah. And you could say
academia can be another one
and so on that's involved.
So those individuals who could
navigate across the sectors
is really important.
We think we need not thousands
more, hundreds cells, but really
millions more bridge builders.
And when I speak at
universities, in grad schools, which
I do all the time, this is the sort
of thing young people really want to
do. It gets them really excited,
and.
That's because they get to be the
orchestra conductor, right?
They're not third oboe.
Or they might want to be.
Not all of them want to be the
conductor.
What goes into that then?
I mean, is it, you know,
is it like is it getting people
to shift between these
sectors like during the course
of their career?
I think absolutely.
Having that sort of thing where
people might spend some time in
government, some time in private
industry, you might work at a
foundation, a nonprofit, and
being able to move across those
sectors, even have tours of duty
where you might go into the private
sector or public sector, because
if they don't understand each other,
if you're in government and you
don't understand the value that the
private sector can bring
to a big initiative, you're
going to have a hard time then
creating as much value as you
could.
But those that we found that
were very successful really had that
deep understanding of the different
sectors. That's why NASA's tried to
do so much to create those various
channels.
And we do have some tours of
duty now in the federal level, US
Digital Service or Aetna
for White House Innovation
Fellows.
I think we need a lot more of that.
When you say other words of duty and
it's people have like kind of term
limited.
Yeah, they may go in for three
years to five years and
then move back out again.
You know, one of the
undertakings that you talk about
in the book, which is really
interesting, is Operation Warp
Speed or, you know, the kind of
federal response to COVID.
Right? And this is,
you know, I think without
being overtly ideological about
it, it's, you know, like at the
highest level possible, it's kind of
a clusterfuck.
You had, you know, the FDA and the
CDC and a bunch of other agencies
shutting down, you know, the early
people who are trying to figure out
what was going on to do early
testing. They, you know, kind
of threw a monopoly blanket
over different parts of the
response.
But Operation Warp Speed,
which was Trump's kind
of saying, okay, we're going to
spend we're going to give a lot of
money with relatively few strings
attached to people who produce
vaccines.
Talk about that.
And how how is Operation
Warp Speed like a great example
of what you're talking about?
And then where does it fall short?
Yeah, I think you can look at
Operation Warp Speed.
Another example we talk about in the
book is the Human Genome Project.
We are still benefiting from
decades, decades later, and
I've had my genome mapped.
Have you? Have you?
I have 23.
So, yeah, you know, close enough.
And I mean, it's interesting because
Francis Collins, who was,
you know, the hero of that story,
is one of the villains really, of,
you know, I think reason has written
about this in trying to shut down
various kind of responses to the
state and during COVID.
But be that as it may.
Yeah. Let's talk about so.
When you look at Operation Warp
Speed, I think what is a
very successful public private
effort, public
sector as both a funder
convener for this.
But what they did was a number of
important things they.
Set very, very clear goals
and, you know, get shots in
people's arms as quickly as possible
and prevent as many deaths as
we can.
They did a lot of deregulation,
administer the regulatory relief,
which was really, really key in
this place.
They did the funding and they
actually then let the private
sector, they gave them the freedom
and flexibility to come up
with different solutions.
And it wasn't a heavy touch.
It was more of a light touch working
with them.
So this is where they kind of
created certain frameworks
and then said, like, as long as
you're within this, right, you know,
do what you're going to do.
I mean, it's kind of fascinating
because and, you know, the book
recounts this when COVID
hit and people are like, okay, we
need a vaccine.
The best minds were all saying,
well, you know, it could be like 3
to 5 years.
Nobody was expecting,
you know, to go from, you know,
January, February, March of 2020
to having shots in the arm.
You know, by Thanksgiving.
I mean, Trump said it.
Nobody believed him.
Right. But it did happen.
So how does that you
know, at the same time,
there's issues, right?
Like where in order to expedite
the, you know, getting shots
in the arm, the government says,
okay, we're definitely we're were
committing to buying a lot of this
stuff, whether kind of whether we
need it or not that clearly we
needed it.
They also immunize companies
against certain kinds of legal
things. So like, how do you balance
all of that in in this
kind of framework?
How do you do the cost benefit
analysis of figuring out, okay,
well, you know, yeah, we're
going to make sure that they can't
be sued or that they maintain
intellectual property rights,
even if some of the money that they
use to develop it comes from
taxpayers and things like that.
Well, in this case, it
was we saw an existential
sort of a threat.
And and so what they're able
to do is that a lot I mean, all
during COVID in ways good and
bad, a lot of the traditional
procedures and regulations
and everything the government had, a
lot of those were waived.
And all of a sudden we saw
telehealth, which had been
impossible to do for all sorts of
regulatory reasons for decades, then
come online and
now we're never going back.
We saw cloud computing, we
saw people working remotely.
So it's oftentimes during these
situations of crisis and disaster
that you're able to do
a lot of looking at every rule and
regulation and whether it makes
sense or not, and you're going to
waive it. And recently I live
on the West Coast as East
Coast, as do you neck and
you remember I-95
and essentially the bridge
collapsed.
Yeah.
And outside
of Philadelphia,
they estimated it was going to take
five months for
it to be fixed.
And that would have just created
massive congestion problems,
all sorts of other issues.
And Governor Josh SHAPIRO said,
you know, and every single
regulation that gets in the way of
getting this done quickly,
we're going to wave at this point.
And what did they do through a
public private partnership, mostly a
lot of private sector innovation,
including bringing in NASCAR
engineers to
help with it.
They were able to get that bridge
fixed in 12,
12 days.
And one of the things that we talk
a lot about in the book is what are
the lessons we can learn from this
disaster response when government is
able to move very, very quickly
and you need to then rethink a lot
of the current regulations so
government can be a lot more agile.
So what happens, though, because,
you know, with things like
telehealth, I mean, this might be a
little bit different, but, you know,
various states waived people
having to get certified in their
state in order to practice medicine,
etc., things like that.
A lot of workplace restrictions
and regulations, a lot of things
were waived during COVID.
And then they start to come back.
Right. And the FDA,
you know, you know, the FDA
is not an agile organization,
right? And they want to go back to
the status quo before
COVID and things like that.
How do you work to,
you know, lock in the liberating
aspects of a de-regulated
kind of crisis environment?
And we during COVID, I've heard
a lot of studies on
what are the lessons learned, how do
we overturn orthodoxies
and so on? Can we learn?
And the speed at which government
move then was kind of unprecedented
in many respects.
And so it was like that.
You're never going to have that over
a long period of time because we do
have checks and balances
and democratic processes and
so on to go forth.
But what we don't want to do is go
back to that old way.
You want to learn a lot of the
lessons and hopefully have a new
normal. Right.
And that's really the key point and
new normal looking at
based on lessons from those
different crises. This is.
Do you think we've done that with,
you know, it related to
things like vaccines or the
delivery of medicine post COVID?
Like, have we learned lessons
that are going to reset how we do
things?
We certainly are.
My my center produces
50 to 60 studies a year
on government management and
technology.
And we look a lot at public, private
and just around research and
development from the
standpoint of medicine,
pharmaceuticals and so on.
There's a lot of rethinking going on
on that and how to do that better,
how to use more open innovation
models within those processes.
How do we speed things up?
And there's actually a lot of ways
you can use technology.
Are there like who are the
constituents for that?
Because it's, you know, it's
I'm thinking of the political
dynamics and it's like during COVID,
obviously, no congressman
or, you know, no, no elected
official wanted to be the person
was like, here, put this in your
arm. And then like a lot of people
die.
But, you know,
you know, do they have an incentive
to, you know,
once the crisis is gone to
be like, yeah, you know, what we
should be doing as we should.
The government should be doing less
in terms of regulating or
or overseeing everything.
I think it's less about doing
less and regulate than new
regulatory models and using
technology where I'm
doing a lot of work right now and
Gen I and I
and regulation and looking at that
and you can dramatically speed
up all sorts of these processes
simply by using technology.
I mean Markt Andreasen years ago
in his manifesto that software he
eats every.
Day the.
Leads the world.
And he also he wrote
one at the beginning of COVID time
to build which didn't
which didn't extend to a,
you know, a middle
income housing development that was
adjacent to one of his properties
where he tried to get it quashed.
But yeah.
So it's about having regulatory
processes which are more agile,
which are outcome based,
which are looking at one of the
areas that we're seeing governments
all over the world do is regulatory
sandboxes.
We've seen that in the fintech area.
Yeah, explain that.
That's essentially where you bring
in the UK has been a leader
in this area.
You bring them into a sandbox
essentially and you enable
them to do various things
that previously weren't allowed
under close supervision.
And what governments are doing is
they're learning from
how those technologies are
progressing.
And instead of going in early with
precautionary regulation,
they're actually stepping back and
they're learning in a more
controlled environment.
And they've even found the startups
that are part of these sandboxes end
up getting more investment money.
They do better over a long period of
time. So it's a very different sort
of model, you know, based on more of
the innovation principle of
regulation.
And I think that's a really positive
things. I was on a World Economic
Forum Futures Council
where we had dozens of regulators
from all over the world who were
looking at these sort of more
flexible models for regulating
emerging technologies because
they're moving too quickly
for those old regulatory models to
work very well.
What what do we do about,
you know, one of the things where
there seems to be a new normal, I
kind of referenced that earlier.
You know, we went from I think
it was in 2019, the federal
budget was like, I think $4.8
trillion, and
then it went up over 6 trillion
very quickly because of COVID,
because of a lot of federal
spending.
And then it went up to 6.8
trillion in 2021.
And, you know, now it's down a
little bit from that.
But, you know, this is the kind of
Robert Higgs crisis and Leviathan
model that during a crisis,
government expands, spending
expands, and then it might come down
a little bit, but it doesn't come
back to where it was, how,
you know, how do we steer
clear of that kind of problem?
Well, my focus for the
last couple of decades has really
been on making
government work better.
Right. And as opposed
to the the overall size, I
think those are those are a lot of
policy decisions.
They're a lot of based on first
principles.
We don't seem to be having that
debate in America
or many other countries around the
world right now.
And I think, you know,
depending on where interest rates go
and the debt situation, that may
bring a lot of that back again.
But as you've seen with the
model that we have here,
if you're really going to talk about
the size of government and so on,
it needs to be based on where the
government spending actually is
today as opposed to where most
of the debates are on, which is a
very, very tiny fraction
of the U.S. budget.
What do you you know, how
do you I don't know
if you consider yourself like,
you know, a.
Libertarian or, you know, a
small government conservative
or or, you know,
a small government liberal or
progressive or whatever.
But what
you know, if government gets better,
I guess this is my question is
like, if government gets better,
will people demand more of it?
Because I know a lot of libertarians
so that when you say and I've heard
this, you know, and people like Bob
Paul and people at Reason Foundation
who help implement better
government policies, people you
know, I know a lot of libertarians
who will say, you know, why would
you want to do that? I want
government to suck as hard as
possible because then people
will get rid of it.
Is this is that borne out by data
or, you know, explain to,
you know, libertarian like through a
narco capitalist why it's actually
worth their time to
have a government that, you know,
runs its schools well?
Well, this is a great discussion.
And we we had this discussion over a
decade ago.
Yeah. And and I actually
even did a piece Why
libertarians should stop hating
government kind of because actually
the data is pretty clear
that those governments, when
you have worse government, more
bureaucratic government and so on,
government can't get things done.
It ends up being bigger, growing
bigger over time.
Which is very counterintuitive, but.
It's because people keep putting
more and more money into things and
they're not working. And then you
have all these processes and
bureaucratic and sclerotic process.
A lot of rent seeking involved,
a lot of bureaucracy and
so on. So in fact, and just think
about things in our everyday lives
that it does make a big difference.
So I ask a lot of people, what's
the biggest innovation in government
in the last decade or so that has
made a difference in your lives?
And for business travelers, it's
things like TSA pre
and global entry
and even clear which is more of
a private sector. I, I just traveled
to Europe.
I was in London.
I was in Paris and then back here
I breezed through the airport
in ways that was similar to pre
911 and that was were based
on having these systems
that broke trade offs.
Innovation is about breaking trade
offs. So TSA PreCheck global
entry, they broke that trade up
between having more security
and convenience and they said we can
actually have both.
So there are a lot of different ways
that by reducing friction,
by making government better, more
efficient, it can actually improve
our lives. It can actually lead to
a much better business climate.
I mean, think about the countries
where government doesn't work at
all. Very rarely is that business
climate very good either,
because there's so much friction in
the system or in
some of those countries where then
you have a lot of both corruption
in the system. So, you know,
I've always believed that better
government can lead to more freedom
for individuals, a better economic
climate for businesses.
And I think the data shows that out
pretty clearly.
Yeah, it's a couple of years ago,
more than a few.
I wrote a story about how,
you know, it's widely observed by
economists and sociologists and
whatnot around the globe that as
societies go from high trust to low
trust, you know, corruption
increases and people know the
government is corrupt, but they ask
it to do more and more for them.
And, you know, in the United
States, in the reverse way, like
during the nineties and, you
know, certainly Bill Clinton,
you know, he didn't mean to elect
a Republican majority
in the House, in the Senate, you
know, but the way things ended up
shaking out government got better
at what it was doing.
It stopped doing certain things.
They balanced the budget.
Yeah. And, you know, and we
actually, you know, government
the size, scope and spending of
government, relatively speaking,
declined.
And then under Bush,
when government started doing a lot
of different things and it was not
going well whether it was in the
economy or wars and things like
that, government grew.
So it's an interesting
I mean, I take some flak
for this and I you know, I
understand why, but the idea is
that, like libertarians won the
argument that, you know, the
government can't do anything well,
and that doesn't lead to people
saying, okay, I don't want
government.
It leads to them saying, well, I
want more.
I want more government.
And then they're facing a
frustration. So in that in the UK,
if you're the death of a loved one,
previously you had to notify already
over 40 different agencies
type in that same information again
and again and again. You weren't in
that condition to do so.
You're grieving for a loved one.
They switched it to a process
using digital government called Tell
US once.
Now you just have to tell the
government once what that is and
they get information out to all
these all the other agencies.
And increasingly, I think,
you know, the leading governments in
the world around innovation
and things like Estonia, Singapore,
trying to figure out they're talk of
frictionless government, they're
talking about personalized
government, basing things on life
events. When you lose a job
or you're going on to college or
the birth of a.
Child, the death of a loved one, how
we organize services
around that.
Again, to reduce all of that
friction that currently exists
in the effort and the system.
And now with AI and digital
government, we really have the
ability to turbo charge that
more than we've ever seen before.
Who who are the politicians
in America who you think
are doing the best job of really
kind of pushing into
a new model where it's not okay,
you know, when, you know, I'm not
going to give you a job and, you
know, and then your kids and your
family, etc., like that.
But people who are like, you know
what? What we're going to try and do
is just create a general framework
where government helps, but it's not
on the you know, it
it a lot of different people, a lot
of different innovation is
happening.
Well, I think when we look at
it from a bridge building
standpoint,
government politicians who
have made that kind of a key part of
their governing philosophy.
One of the individuals we talk a lot
about is John Hickenlooper when
he was mayor of Denver
and then governor of Colorado,
extremely popular, then
across the different parties.
And he made public private
partnerships at the center of his
governing philosophy.
And he was always looking at how do
we create mutual advantage between
the sectors, always reaching out to
them. And that actually brought in
a lot of bipartisan support to
support from companies.
He was able to raise over $295
million towards these
public initiatives, and
that was at the very core of
everything he did.
And then as mayor of
New York City, Michael Bloomberg,
again, you know, coming from
the business community and coming
from a foundation community, deeply
understood the sectors.
And so, again, that became a key
part. So you can disagree with all
sorts of other stuff you might have
done. But those were two individuals
who understood how to create
mutual advantage.
And Bloomberg is really interesting
because, you know, I live in New
York, so I talked to a
lot of people who are, you know,
both, you know, at every
stratum of society.
And one of the things, particularly
in the wake of Bill de Blasio and
now Eric Adams, people who
may not have liked many elements
of Bloomberg, they're like, you know
what? Like, you know, trash was
collected better, The roads were
kept better for the most part.
And it was a good business climate
which made everything better off
where you know, but it Bloomberg
like we're not going to see the
likes of him very often right
And I'm not, you know, totally
saying he was great by any stretch,
but that you know, that
type of person who has, you know,
government experience, nonprofit
experience and business experience,
like, you know, that just
he's kind of a unicorn in that.
Right. Well, Governor, I find really
interesting as someone you've had
in your podcast before, is Governor
Jared Polis from
Colorado.
Yeah. Who I think is.
He's like a center millionaire from
an online greeting card company.
He really understands technology
really well.
I think that his his beliefs
are a little bit iconoclastic
in certain ways, which I find really
interesting, and doing a really
good job governing the state and
on the other side of the
country, in a way, he's no longer
governor. But Larry Hogan,
as governor of Maryland, was very
pragmatic, business oriented,
and he, along with
another moderate Republican then
Charlie Baker from Massachusetts,
were two of the most popular
governors in the country.
What was what you know,
what did Hogan do?
And he's always being floated as
like a third, you know, a No Labels
type candidate, etc..
Also had to work with a super
Democratic legislature and stuff.
But like, what were you know, what's
the takeaway from a from a Larry
Hogan that should be replicated
in other places.
But the takeaway is problem
solving, focus on solving
problems. He was very pragmatic.
The state was run well.
They had a lot of innovation in
areas like workforce development,
which is a huge issue in the.
Way.
Among most governors.
The notion of upskilling the
workforce to meet 21st century
needs, whether it's in AI
or or solar or wind,
is really one of their most
important topics.
Areas of issue
orient. And what Hogan did
as governor was they had something
called Earned Maryland,
which in contrast to most workforce
development programs, it was
industry led, which
meant that they said, you know,
industry knows a lot better
than we do as government officials
what their needs are.
And so we're going to let
them apply for grants together
and we're going to give out
competitive grants to industries,
usually different nonprofits
who are running these different
things. And they're going to they're
going to create the curriculum and
they're going to change it. We're
going to let them be very agile
depending on the very changing
workforce needs.
And that was just what and it was
very successful program we talk
about in the book as a real model.
And that's where a lot of other
states are now going and work for
development. But he had a lot of
initiatives like that, which are
very, very, I would say, pragmatic,
business minded, focused on what
works.
What do you think of people like
Ron DeSantis and Greg Abbott?
You know, Texas and Florida,
and they very much
kind of push back.
If you look at, you know, you know,
Texas, I talked to Jeb Bush
recently, who's somebody you're very
familiar with.
But, you know, Florida, California,
Texas, New
York are the four most populous
states in the country.
And it's an interesting thing where
California and New York are
very much kind of blue models
of states.
They have high taxes, high
regulation, and they promise a high
level of government services.
Whether they deliver that or not
is a different question than, you
know, Florida and Texas are
red models, right, where they say
we're going to cut government, we're
going to we don't have an income
tax, we don't regulate business
as much.
You know, our Abbott and DeSantis
doing something right because that's
like Florida had more people moved
to it than any other state
last year.
You know, how how do you evaluate
somebody like a DeSantis and
and it and Greg Abbott.
Well I don't want to comment on
those individual politicians.
The one thing I would say, though,
in the kind of climate
we're in, which is so partizan
and so ideological
that oftentimes we're failing
to see some of the positives
in a lot of different states.
So let's say California
right now, you
know, California's pretty well
positioned for
the next wave or the air revolution
with literally well over
half of all of the leading
air tech air companies
out of California, as well as
climate tech and other areas.
So I think a lot of the states have
different things going for them.
And what we should be looking at as
as a country where
the different regions that are Excel
are that are excelling in different
technology areas and whether
the best way is supporting them,
creating those economic climates
for getting ready for this is
really we're in the fourth
industrial revolution, Ascension,
which is an AI and digital
revolution, and we're going to have
to compete against
the rest of the world in that
respect.
So what what's good in Florida,
though, I mean, leave the Santos
out. Why? You know, why are so many
people moving there?
Why are jobs growing
there?
It's just not my area, necessarily.
Okay.
Let me ask, as you know, your
first book, I believe, was
Revolution at the Roots, Right.
That you wrote with John O'Leary.
And if I'm remembering correctly,
that had a blurb from Newt Gingrich
on it and this was
in the mid-nineties, it was
interesting. And I think with
even by the end of the nineties,
people recognize that Newt Gingrich
was, you know, there was something
wrong with him.
But there was that interplay
of like him and Bill Clinton, who,
you know, were like weird twins,
right? I mean, they're both sons
of the South. They're both
intellectual, you know, raised
by kind of odd single mothers
and distant fathers and all.
I mean, it's just it's fascinating
that they were around at the same
time.
But can you reflect a little bit
on your like the political or
ideological or intellectual journey
that you've been on over the past 30
years? Because that I mean,
you know, what did Revolution at the
Roots get right?
What did it get wrong?
And, you know, where are you now
in relation to where you started?
Well, I think the most important
thing about my intellectual journey
is I've really tried to
focus increasingly
on what the data
shows, what is the evidence show,
and to avoid what we
talked about in one of our books,
John and I, which is called the
Tolstoy Syndrome, which essentially
confirmation bias.
Yeah. And and to really
be focused on what's working,
what's not working, how do we change
these systems?
Because, you know, at at the city
level, Nick, you can't govern by
ideology.
It just doesn't work.
That's not how you get potholes
filled or anything else.
It's all about really nitty
gritty of the system.
So I really focus more and more of
my time and attention on
understanding these systems,
understanding policy implementation,
because I believe that when you
look at $1,000,000,000 going
into think tanks in America, in many
respects, like the
percentage of that that actually
talks about how do you make these
things work is is very, very low.
And even look at something like
originally California electricity
deregulation.
It was passed unanimously.
Which was the first sign that it was
not a good.
Idea because they they essentially
wrote it to pass the legislature,
not to work in the real world.
And of course, Enron was able
to game that system.
So what they didn't spend enough
time is wargaming all.
All the ways that this could go
wrong and really looking at market
design. So so my work has really
been focused in that
in that respects looking at these
systems and how do you structure the
systems and markets and incentives
the best way to create the most
public value?
Are you optimistic?
I mean, we're in a very,
you know, fraught, polarized
period, you know,
and certainly discourse is not good.
People seem to be
more tribally identifying
with one side or the other when it
comes to Democrats and Republicans.
Are you optimistic
about, you know, the next five or
ten years of that changing
or.
Yeah, it's like it doesn't really
matter.
Well, it's one of the one of the
reasons why I've always loved your
work and Matt's work, because you
have pointed out
time and time again
all the different ways things are
getting better.
And we have so much
pessimism now and
almost nihilism in certain respects.
And yet when you look at the next
5 to 6 years or so,
the U.S. is incredibly well
positioned for the future, if
we can take advantage of it.
About three fourths of the leading
AI companies in the world out of the
50 top are from the U.S.
We have the we have the overwhelming
number of companies that
are engaged in climate technology
and investments in that area.
And space is another area.
We do have the best kind of
innovation ecosystem set
up between universities,
private sector research labs,
federal government funding and so
forth in the world in
many respects. And we're ranked
number three behind Sweden and
Switzerland, I believe, in terms of
innovation, climate.
And the U.S. said there's there's a
lot of really positive things
there and you don't read about that
at all.
And and the sentiment from
voters is so negative in many
respects.
And it doesn't it doesn't actually
connect with what the data show.
So is that is that a problem
that, you know, people are living
you know, they think they're living
in a world that, you
know, a dystopia that's mostly
in their head?
Well, obviously, some
some people are suffering.
Inflation's been going up and
everything. But even among the
experts and among the people who
are on TV, the reality
right now and when
you look at the data, it doesn't
jive at all with the negative
ism and the pessimism that we see.
And it's not only in the U.S.
we see some of this in a lot of
other parts of the world.
But I was just in India six
months ago and absolutely
amazing. So much more positive
energy. But I was in something
called a tech city in Hyderabad,
where there's hundreds
of thousands of tech workers working
it for U.S. companies, international
companies becoming middle
class, upper middle class.
And ten years ago, it didn't even
exist. It was forest land.
And so there's a lot of more hope
there. And I just think we need
to regain some of that hope
in order to move forward.
Because, you know, as the work of
Steven Pinker has showed and others,
a lot of things are getting a lot
better.
Final question, Put this
in generational context.
You know, it seems like younger
people, younger millennials and Gen
Z are pretty pessimistic.
I mean, they have been
they've been raised marinating
in a story about climate disaster
and climate apocalypse, about,
you know, about
not being able to afford a car, a
house, not being able to get a full
time job. All of these things, all
of which I you know, without going
into detail, we can say, okay, these
are all overblown.
But, you know, is
our younger generations
likely to be optimistic?
And, you know, if they are
or, you know, are they more likely
to go into the private sector, into
government or are they, you know,
somebody like Peter Thiel at the end
of 0 to 1
talked about how, you know, to many
of us now, particularly young people
are waiting for the future to be
invented rather than,
you know, kind of doing it
ourselves.
You know, how how do
the dynamics that you're talking
about play out among younger people?
Well, I'm not an expert on
generations.
I have seen a lot of that data
which which I think is very
concerning. But one area that
I do find really interesting.
I'm a big science fiction fan.
And if you look
at the science fiction from decades
ago, Robert Heinlein
and others, a lot of it showed
this sort of utopian vision of
the future and inspired
people like Elon Musk and Peter
Thiel and many
others. And the science fiction
over the last few decades has almost
all been dystopian.
And so it's hard
for people to see this really
positive future because
you don't see a lot of it in in
our popular culture today.
And and so
where where do they get to see in
terms of what the possibilities
are?
I think if you look out to 2040
and others, when we have
A.I. embedded into every element
of our society in various
ways, and I think there's a lot to
be optimistic about and bullish
about.
But if people never see that, if
they never see the vision, that's
I think that's.
Really not a lot of positive
stories about A.I..
Could you and I said that was the
last thing I want to ask you real
quick.
You know, can you just very quickly
sketch how A.I.
is going to make everyday life
better? Because this, you know, it's
fascinating and it follows
a very kind of understandable
cycle, like a new technology
reaches a certain level, and then
everybody's like, this is the end of
the world. And it's like, not
really, but, you know, make Can
you make a quick case for how AI
is going to make life better for us?
Well, people talk about AI being the
the new electricity
and all the different thing about
all the different ways electricity
changed our lives.
Even even in Manhattan,
where you live, the development, the
skyscrapers. It used to be if you
were really wealthy, you'd live on
the bottom floors because you didn't
want a Hawk-Eye.
So electricity
went into every element of our lives
in manufacturing and the homes and
everything, and it transformed it.
But it took us a couple of decades
to figure out all the changes and
processes to realize that
now what's actually going to happen
a little bit faster, I think, with
AI. But just think about things
such as foreign languages.
Well, there's already something
out today where I can be speaking to
you. You can be speaking in Japanese
and I can be speak.
In this.
Italian.
Even older. But I don't know if it
counts as utopian or dystopian.
But Douglas
Adams saying Checkered sky, the
whole kind of idea of a babble and
which is one of them is called,
right? Yeah.
So there's that.
And I guess there's things like
helping to maintain schedules
and things like that.
Like think about writing.
Yeah, you know, a lot of people
aren't that great writing.
It's their third language, second
language, and all of a sudden they
can put them through an AI
tool on that that is able to
do that. You have the world's
knowledge at your fingertips in
you're able to pull all
of that. We're going to have
productivity increases go up.
We probably going have more leisure
time.
We're not going to be tied to our
phones anymore because it's going to
be with gestural sort of interfaces
in the real world.
Any time we go to see any sort of
a monument or anything else will be
able to understand the history of
it. Just looking at it from
augmented reality, we won't need to
train children to desk
sitting in desk all day long because
they'll be out in the real world
learning about it.
And with a digital overlay over it,
there's a million ways it's going to
be really exciting.
And it's we're seeing we're
seeing the kind of exponential
breakthroughs right now in
AI. The technology is increasing at
the kind of rate that we saw with
Moore's Law and the digital
technologies.
And so we don't know exactly how
it's all going to turn out.
But I tell you, I'm pretty excited
about it.
Yeah.
Is there anything that can really
kind of screw that up?
Well, obviously, you've
got to have the right regulatory
regimes and we're looking
at a lot.
Of preferably little to none
either for my side, but.
For there, there's some harm that
can be prevented.
You know, obviously, I think a lot
of the fears on
some of the very existential fears
people have on AI right now are way
overblown. We're not anywhere near
artificial general intelligence
right now, certainly from a I
think from a warfare perspective
and so on, and drones and
autonomous drones.
I think there's some real dangers
there, but certainly there's a lot
of different dangers.
But we always have faced those with
different technologies and
we've been able to overcome them.
And I think we understand what those
are better now than we did with
social media technologies
of two decades ago.
Yeah.
All right. We're going to leave it
there.
The book is Bridge Builders How
Government Can Transcend Boundaries
to Solve Big Problems.
The coauthor is William Dugas.
Well, thank you for talking to
reason.
Thanks, Nick. Great to be back with
you.